Ah, die ist so köstlich! Was macht diese Banane so köstlich? Vielleicht, dass du drei Monate lang nichts gegessen hast. Ey, das ist wirklich die leckerste Banane, die ich je gegessen habe. Ich habe gerade eine Banne manchmal. Ja. Dass man einfach mal was isst, mal wieder seit langer Zeit. Komm, ich rutsche mal ein bisschen ran. Und dann hat man das Gefühl, das schmeckt wahnsinnig gut. Dieser bananige Geschmack, vollmundig, sagt man auch. Was heißt das, wenn was vollmundig ist? Das ist ein sehr vollmundiges, glaube ich. Ist weniger. Ich habe gerade ein großes Stück abgebissen und ich hatte wirklich ein vollmundiges Bananen. Schling nicht so viel, sag mal auch. Ja. Nun schling nicht. Zu Kindern redet man ganz anders. Ich habe das Gefühl, wenn du mit Leuten sprichst und drehen die sich um zu ihrem Kind, dann switch das Gehirn auf so eine Kindersprache. Nun schling nicht so viel, Michael. Ja, stopf nicht so. Hast du das schon jemals gemacht? Niemand würde das zum Erwachsenen sagen, nun schlingen sie nicht so. Kau mal mehr. Also immer positiv. Mach mal nicht. Schön kauen. Kau mal mehr. Ich finde, man sollte versuchen, generell alles im Leben positiv zu formulieren. Also nicht hör auf mit, sondern versuch mal, mich weniger anzurufen. Versuch mal nicht drei Uhr morgens. Wahnsinnig passivaggressiv. Versuch mal nicht, vielleicht das grösste Arschloch zu sein, okay? Probier mal nächste Woche nicht um drei Uhr nachts noch laut Scherzuhören. Guck mal, wie es für dich funktioniert. Also einfach als Experiment für dich. Versuch mal nicht mehr zuzunehmen. Weil es wird ja auch irgendwann schwierig. Irgendwann musst du auch Jura studieren, um diese doppelte Verneinigungungen hinzubekommen. Versuch mal nicht die ganze Packung Snickers zu essen, sondern nur ein Snickers. Aber diese Banane ist wirklich, also köstlich, wirklich, also wirklich schmackhaft. Nee, die sieht auch gut aus, die ist nicht so, ich sag mal unreif grün, wo dann auch in der Mitte noch sehr weiss ist, sondern die schon, dieses gelbliche, der ganze Raum füllt sich mit diesem Aroma. Die hat genau die richtige Reifegrad und ich habe das Gefühl, bei Banane ist alles, also Banane hat zwei Teile, alles was schlecht ist, Schale und alles was gut ist, die Banane, wohingegen bei, jetzt was weiß ich, bei einer Birne, da hast du dann in der Mitte
noch so Gekrösel und Kerne.
Oh, beim Granatapfel. Ja, da hast du gute Stellen schlecht.
Die Proportionen stimmen nicht.
Bei einer Banane stimmt die Proportionen.
Es ist wie so eine, die Natur hat es schon
clever Packaging. Also das hat die Natur schon
gut gemacht. Es liegt ja auch viel an der Konsistenz.
Und das ist perfekt.
Ist das so blöd ohne Publikum, oder?
Das ist man gar nicht mehr gewohnt. Ich fühle mich so arm. Ja, einsam und ver ist perfekt. Ist das so blöd ohne Publikum, oder? Das ist man gar nicht mehr gewohnt.
Ich fühle mich so arm.
Ja, einsam und verarmt.
Man hört mich die Kassen.
Ich wünschte manchmal bei Roller-Croster-Tycoon,
wenn man was gebaut hat in einem erfolgreichen Park,
da macht es die ganze Zeit,
weil immer wenn jemand durch die Kasse geht,
vor allem im Eingangsbereich,
macht es Kaching.
Und so ein bisschen bei unseren Live-Auftritten hört man den Merchstand auch immer in der Entfernung irgendwo Kaching, Kaching, Kaching. Und heute habe ich keinen Kaching vernommen. Wir haben mal tolles Feedback bekommen zu unserem aktuellen Tourposter von Hoppenbrock. Tatsächlich, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das sagen darf, völliger Zufall des Schicksals, der Bruder von Hoppenbrock war im Publikum. Nee, kein Zufall. Nein. Das war schon Zufall. Wir klären nochmal den Begriff Zufall. Er wusste, er ist wohl Fan, er war da, hatte in Hannover, gewusst, dass wir da auftreten, wusste von dem Poster und hat sich Karten gekauft. Ich weiß, Zufall ist nicht, wenn eine Kette von der eigenen, doch, naja, schon Zufall.
Lustigste Frucht, Banane? Nee. Nee, durch die Bananenschale, nee? Ja, ja gut, schon lustig. Arroganteste Frucht zu essen, Apfel. Denkt man nicht, weil sie ja kommen, aber es ist auf jeden Fall, Apfel macht schon, wenn du Apfel isst, hast du recht. Aber ich finde, Apfel ist so ein bisschen die Marvel-Filme des Obstkorps.
So hat man jetzt auch schon mal gehabt. Ich finde, die Zeit des Apfels ist vorbei. Du hattest die biblische Geschichte, die Origin-Story, wo alle dachten, wow, krasse Story. Du isst den Apfel, du bist aus dem Paradies geworfen. Krass. Geile Story, dann diese ganze Sache mit, an Apple a day keeps the doctor away, dieses pädagogische, dieses auch, jetzt muss man es zum Tausen machen. Dieses Spin-Off-artige. Ja, dieses Spin-Off-artige, dann jetzt kommt der Granatapfel, wo man sich auch denkt, ja. Bratapfel, okay. Wie lange geht das denn gut? Es kocht die alten Sachen einfach nur wieder auf. Der Liebesapfel, der glasierte Apfel. Adamsapfel. Jetzt wird es gemolken, jetzt wird es gemolken. Und für mich ist es ein Punkt erreicht, wo ich sage, jetzt reicht's auch nicht.
Aber auch manche Früchte lassen sich klein machen, manche nicht so. Die Mini-Kiwi ist populär gerade, so die Kiwi, die man so snacken kann, als Weintraubengrosse. Wann kommt der Apfel, der so groß ist? Also Mini-Apfel. Ich glaube, das würde sich durchsetzen, so Apfel ohne Kerne. Wann kommt der kernlose Apfel? Ja, das ist die richtige Frage, weil wenn du es aus Trauben rausbekommst ... Und aus Bananen auch.
Bananen hatten ursprünglich auch so dicke braune Klötze drin.
Ja?
Ja.
Und auch Wassermelonen ja auch noch.
Bei Wassermelonen ist viel schiefgegangen.
Ich glaube, da war vorher ein grosser drin.
Da hat man die gezüchtet, dachte, lange Zeit, wow, es wird besser.
Und jetzt haben wir eine Milliarde kleine Kerne bei mir drin. Ja, oder es war früher ein riesiger Kern. Es war früher nur ein Kern. Und dann irgendwann haben wir eine Melone draus bekommen. Ja, und dann war so ein ganz kleines Stückchen Rot. Und dann so, das ist ja köchlich, das ist rot, mehr von dem Rot. Bananen waren früher auch rund. Und dann fragen sich ja viele, warum ist die Banane krumm? Und die ist krumm, weil man jetzt die Kerne raus, aber naja, die Kerne raus für haben sollte, jetzt hat man aber leider auch die langgezüchtet.
Ja, aber so ist es doch, so funktioniert das Züchtung. Man kreuzt querbeet und guckt, was rauskommt. Und dann so, oh, die Kerne sind kleiner, es ist süsser und dann geht man mehr in die Richtung. Man hat jetzt übrigens einen, und das wäre immer die Frage, warum domestiziert man keine Bären oder andere Tiere als Hunde und Katzen?
Und man hat sich jetzt dazu entschlossen, auch, und schon länger macht man das in Russland, Füchse zu domestizieren. Gute Idee. Und dann meine erste Google-Suchanfrage danach war, sind Füchse eher Hund oder eher Katze? Weil es ist so, es ist nicht ein, ich dachte erst in meinem Kopf, doofe Frage, Google war auch der Meinung, ich dachte Google wäre meiner Meinung und es ist vielleicht keine doofe Frage, aber auch Google war jetzt eher so schüchtern, also eher zurückhalten, Google war okay, das ist schon eine unübliche Frage. Alexa geht so in Standby so, mach mal für dich selber gerade. Google hat jetzt für die ganz offensichtlichen Sachen, haben die jetzt mittlerweile auch diese FAQs, wo man direkt draufklicken kann. Ja, wo man genau weiss, du bist auf dem richtigen Weg. Ja. Du weißt genau, oh, es läuft. Und ist Fuchs eher Hund oder eher Katze? Hatte das noch nicht? Wo man sagt, okay, hier bin ich gleich gerade in so einer Ecke, wo man sich ein bisschen häufiger umgucken sollte, mal, weil diese Ecke des Internets ist mir nicht geheuer. Du hast neues Terrain betreten. Ich habe neues Terrain erschlossen. Aber tatsächlich ist es mehr Hund. Hätte ich jetzt auch gesagt, weil... Also ich unterscheide jetzt zwischen knicken die oder knicken die nicht. Und Hund knickt nicht. Katze knickt. Also wenn du die in der Mitte des Körpers hochnimmst, knicken die oder nicht? Also sacken die zusammen oder nicht? Da hast du manche Hundearten noch nicht gesehen.
Die können knicken, holy shit.
Die Möpse, denen ist alles scheißegal.
Da ist auch mittlerweile alles,
alle Gedärme weggezüchtet. Die haben nur noch
Gesicht und Pfoten.
Ja, aber das hat was mit der Wirbelsäule zu tun,
dass die nicht knicken. Und so ein Pferd knickt auch nicht, glaube ich,
wenn du das hochnimmst. Und Katzen können sich ja so
einrollen, Luchs, kannst du hochnennen,
knickt.
Skampi knickt. Ja, ja. Scampis sind vielleicht die Katzen der Meere, wer weiß. Am Wochenende habe ich mir eine Gamba-Pfanne gemacht. Moment, Gamba ist eins. Ich habe mich gerade nicht entscheiden können, zwischen Ganele, Gamba, Gamba und Scampen. Ich wusste gerade nicht. Also Scampi, Gamba, Ganele. Scampi ist von Plural. Scampo, Scampus ist Singular. Scampi sind mehr. Was ist nämlich zwischen Ganele, Krebs, Scampi und Gamba? Das ist eines dieser faszinierenden Tiere, wo man einfach gesagt hat, wir sind uns mit der Größe noch nicht ganz. Rummer, ist Rummer nicht ein großer Scampi? Ja, man sagt so, Elefant ist die perfekte Größe, Rüssel ist gut lang, Beine sind schön stark perfekt, aber so beim Scampi sag mal so, lass uns mal Varianten machen, lass uns mal so von ganz klein bis grossen, einfach mal gucken öffnet. Die sind alle gelaufen. Und da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, ich glaube am Ende war es Krebs dann doch und da ist der ganze Körper essbar. Krebs? Ja, Gamba. Auch die Stiebe? Okay, bleiben wir. Gambo! Häng dich nicht am, ich habe gerade gesagt, häng dich nicht am Wort auf. Sagen wir Gamba. Der schlechteste Biologe der Welt.
Häng dich jetzt mal nicht am Wort auf.
Häng dich an den Begriff, häng dich nicht an den, verstehe ich, Wissenschaftler, häng dich jetzt nicht an den Details auf.
Jetzt häng dich mal nicht an Photon auf gerade.
Nee, wir müssen hier beim Zern schon darauf achten. Wenn hier was schief bleibt, haben wir ein schwarzes Loch erschaffen.
Ich sag mal Elektron, aber jetzt lass uns einmal mal machen. Nageln Sie mich nicht drauf fest. Also du hast eine schöne Fischpfanne gemacht, einfach schöne Krabben. So, schön Krabben, naja, und da Krabben ist klein, Krabben ist kleiner. Es waren so, es waren große Sachen und dann muss man tendenziell nur die Beine abknipsen und diesen Panzer abmachen und den Kopf ab und dann hast du Fleisch, da ist nichts drin. Wo sind die Gedärme eines gemeinen Gambo? Wirbel soll, ne haben die nicht, Wirbeltiere. Ne, es sind ja wirbelose Tiere, ich glaube, Schalentiere sind das. Stimmt, ja. Und die werden tatsächlich einfach, also die Proportionen, essbar, unessbar, sind für das Tier denkbar schlecht, für den Menschen denkbar gut. Ja, es ist die Banane der Meere. Du hast die Schale und das Fleisch, aber wo hast du denn so einen Krebs her? Von der Gourmetheke. Ein Krebs einfach? Ausgesuchte Supermarktmärkte haben mehrere. Wie viele Krebs hast du vergessen? Ich weiß nicht, ob Krebs, es riecht ja schon Krebsfleisch drunter, aber vielleicht waren die Schilder vertauscht. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Rückblickend war es auch die falsche Zutat für meine Pfanne, weil ich dachte, die werden schön gross, wenn man die anbrät. Die wurden weich und grösser, viel grösser, so aufgegangen wie so ein Hefeteich. Rückblickend bin ich mir nicht sicher, was es war genau. Aber wie gesagt,
nageln Sie mich nicht darauf fest,
zurück zu unserem schwarzen Loch.
Aber Fuchs, demistizierter Fuchs, finde ich, ist eine sehr gute Idee.
Ein unterschätztes Tier.
Und es war sehr einfach, nämlich
kurzer Einschub, die haben einfach gesagt,
gut, was zeichnet ein Fuchs aus?
Aggressiv.
Was wollen wir nicht in unseren Füchsen?
Aggressivität. Also haben die gesagt, wir kreuzen die am wenigsten fuchsartigen Füchse, also die unaggressivsten Füchse mit den unaggressivsten Füchsen. Also ich dachte so Fuchs und Schlaftier. Wie sind die? Faultier. Fuchs und Faultier. Und dann aggressiv, aber langsam. Genau, vor allem aber Faultiere haben wahnsinnig große Krallen, da muss man die da wegzüchten und so einen Scheiß. Faultiere böten sich doch auch an, als Haustier, oder? Kleiner Bad-Fact zum Thema Faultiere. Faultiere gehen einmal in der Woche aufs Klo. Ja? Dafür klettern sie extra vom Baum, weil die müssen vom Baum runter dafür. Die sind bestimmt einfach faul.
Und es dauert ewig, und damit die nicht
ständig nur hoch und runter klettern,
sind die so angelegt, dass sie nur einmal
in der Woche aufs Klo müssen.
Manchmal greifen die
schon nach etwas, was gar nicht mehr da ist.
Weil die Augen auch irgendwie,
die sind einfach alles, an denen sagt,
gib mir noch fünf Minuten. Es gibt mir noch fünf Minuten Tier. Ruf morgen nochmal an. Und das ist das übrigens in der schönsten Sätze, wir machen das in Ruhe. Wir machen das morgen in Ruhe. Das ist das Tier, was das ausstrahlt. Zurück zu den Füchsen. Man hat also gesagt, die wenigsten aggressiven Frauen werden mit den wenigsten aggressiven Männchen gek werden mit den wenigsten aggressiven Männchen gekreuzt. Und dann hat man alle anderen getötet und immer die Generation, die am nettesten ist, haben sie mal einen Finger in den Käfig gesteckt und die nicht gebissen haben, hat man genommen. Und dann wurden am Ende daraus zahme Füchse. Wie lange ist denn eine Fuchsgeneration? Also wann können die wieder Kinder kriegen? Ich glaube, es geht schon relativ fix, oder? Stunde? Ja. Irgendwas zwischen einem Jahr und einer Stunde, würde ich sagen. Nageln Sie mich nicht. Nageln Sie mich jetzt nicht. Und dann einfach, und dann jetzt hast du einen zahmen Fuchs. Ja, ich jetzt nicht. Der Russe in dem Video hatte dann sehr viele zahme Füchse. Aber die haben sich, glaube ich, nicht so richtig durchgesetzt dann. Doch nicht. Machen Machen glaube ich nicht viele. Ich weiß nicht. Naja, wenn du den Fuchs immer mehr zum Hund machst, dann wird es auch witzlos. Also du willst ja dann, was ist denn am Ende der Kette einfach ein Hund? Ein fuchsähnlicher Hund? Naja, ich meine, Hunde sind ja aus Wölfen entstanden. Wenn man jetzt aus Füchsen auch Hunde macht, dann werden die wahrscheinlich ähnlich. Ist der Fuchs zwischen Hund und Wolf?
Ja, das war auch exakt.
Zwischen Hund und Katze war meine Theorie
dann. Ich dachte, ich hätte
des Rätsels Lösung gefunden, weil ich dachte,
genau auf der Mitte zwischen Hund und Katze
ist Fuchs, nee, deutlich mehr in Richtung
Hund. Aber was ist denn mit
einem Hundgrossen Katze, so Luchse?
Kann man die nicht auch domestizieren oder so?
Ist Luchs die Mischung aus Hund und Katze?
Nee, aus Fuchs und Leguan, das ist Luchs.
Luchs.
Und diese Lichteinheit?
Ich weiß es nicht genau, ehrlich gesagt.
Hektopass, geil.
Ja, schwierig, alles schwierig.
Heute ist so eine Entspanntheit, wir machen heute mal so eine Zwischentür-und-Angelfolge.
Ich glaube, wir haben heute vor allem noch nie so spät aufgenommen, wir heute, immer so Late Night heute. Late Night? Wir haben 16 Uhr. Nee, wir haben 21 Uhr. Was? Ja! Ich habe ja kein Zeitgefühl mehr. Ich habe ja überhaupt kein Zeitgefühl mehr, du bist völlig rausgerissen aus allem, du bist völlig neben der Spur. Nee, plötzlich vor allem, wir haben jetzt das Projekt, in dem ich jetzt arbeite, hat es heute Warm-Up-Party gehabt und Und ich wusste von dem Termin auch nichts. Und dann plötzlich fing das Büro plötzlich an, so murmelig zu werden. Ich habe in meinem Eckbüro gar nichts mitbekommen. Und es klang so wie Weihnachten in der Kirche. Es ist rumgemurmelt, und es rumgemurmelt wird immer lauter. Was murmeln die immer? Und die Stimmen kennt man irgendwie, kann man zuordnen. Und dann plötzlich komme ich raus und es wurde so ein Riesen-Buffet aufgebaut. Da war Sicherheitseinweisung. Und da musste ich etwas unterschreiben auf einem iPad. Muss jeder unterschreiben? Leider war ich der Einzige, der sich verschrieben hat, weshalb er diese ganze Liste nochmal neu anlegen musste, weil er das Radiergummiewerkzeug nicht gefunden hat. Wo man sagen muss, ist das jetzt meine Schuld, weil ich mich verschrieben habe, wo drüber steht leserlicher Name, da habe ich... Kann man sich seinen eigenen Namen verschreiben, Stefan? Ich habe mich in der Spalte vertan. Was war dein Schreibfehler genau? Nee, die Spalte war dreigeteilt. Und du hast Beffer nicht. Nee, da stand Vorname, Nachname, Unterschrift. Wo ich dann die Frage hätte, wenn ich meine Unterschrift mache, impliziert das nicht Vorname und Nachname, wenn man will? Was hast du gemacht? So, ich habe meine Unterschrift bei Vorname hingeschrieben. Und dann rutscht du die Zeile weiter und denkst, ah fuck. Und er auch schon so, oh fuck. Und dann hat er rumgesucht und hat aber dieses Radiergummi-Werkzeug nicht gefunden. Und dann waren die anderen 90 Unterschriften unnötig. Wir müssen jetzt wegen unseres Autoren Stefan, der es nicht hinbekommen hat, seinen Namen hinbekommen. Der beruflich dafür bezahlt wird, zu schreiben. Ja, genau, das war leider das große Problem. Er hat mir ein Foto von dem Buffet geschickt, aber hast nicht die uralte Regel, bring jemandem was vom Buffet mit Regeln mitgebracht. Ja, so, in meiner Theorie, wir haben viele Regeln, wir beiden.
Unter anderem ...
Haben wir lange erarbeitet und einen grossen Regelkollektiven.
Nee, weil man muss sagen, unsere Gesellschaft hat halt manche Regeln einfach nicht klar niedergeschrieben.
So was wie immer bestätigen.
Ja, na ja, okay.
Mussten wir auch erst neulich niederschreiben.
Wo es heißt, wenn man einen Termin bekommt, muss der andere bestätigen.
Immer bestätigen.
Sonst gilt der Termin noch nicht. Sonst einloggen, sagt man ja.in bekommt, muss der andere bestätigen. Sonst gilt der Termin noch nicht.
Einloggen sagt man ja.
Mach mal ein Beispiel für eine Bestätigung.
Wie könnte die aussehen?
Okay, alles klar.
Dito.
Daumen nach oben Smiley.
Bejahen der Smiley.
Dieser Ring Smiley.
Dieser Ring Smiley, dieser Daumen.
Eigentlich fast jeder Emotie ist eine Bestätigung. Der Wegrenn-Smiley weiß ich nicht. Oder ich renne hin. Letztens, also du weißt ja, ich bin ein Socializer. Wenn ich mit Leuten kommuniziere, die ich kenne, benutze ich nie Emojis. Ausschließlich mit Leuten, die ich noch nicht gut kenne, weil da habe ich das Gefühl, kann man sehr leicht Pluspunkte sammeln, indem man einfach Emojis verwendet. Und dann ist es auch gut, dann ist es einfach so ein Boost für deine soziale Kompetenz.
Und das ist auch fast immer wichtig, witzig, also Random Emojis sind häufig lustig.
Ja, und dann schreibe ich ja gerne, weil ich finde Emojis sind immer noch so ein bisschen uncool,
deswegen will ich nicht die richtigen Emojis nutzen, sondern andere, was wahrscheinlich noch wesentlich uncooler ist und eh jeder macht.
Oh, deswegen machst du die Katzen.
Und dann habe ich, nee, sondern halt dann so, ey, kannste kannst du mir was mitbringen ja und dann schreibe ich danke und dann dachte ich mir jetzt noch ein emoji aber jetzt wenn ich den lächelst meidet ist es ja zu zu normal so ich bin ja crazy ich bin ja ironisch aber dann war es nicht so leicht ein emoji zu finden der wirklich gar keine aussage hat darüber hinaus. Ich habe mit einer Frau kommuniziert und da
werden schon mal viele Emojis sein, also dann kannst du
viele Früchte schon mal, weil ein Grossteil der
Früchte haben Ähnlichkeiten zu
menschlichen Anatomie. Okay.
Und wenn jetzt die Gurke, danke Gurke,
so dann denkt man jemand, was soll das denn bedeuten?
Danke Melone Melone.
Ja, danke Fussball Fussball.
Du hast dann lange, winken das
Miley, Fussball Fussball. Du hast dann lange gescrollt, bis ich einen gefunden habe. Dann dachte ich, ich hätte ihn gefunden, aber nach dem Abschicken dachte ich mir, und ich habe das Golfloch genommen. Eingelocht. Eingelocht, weil ich dachte, das ist ein gutes Zeichen für, yes, also positiv. Wir haben das Eingelocht. War das eine Bestätigung? Also war das, wollen wir das bestätigen? So, kannst du mir was mitbringen? Ja, kann ich, danke, Golfloch. Ja, done. Warum gibt es das Golfloch? Wie willst du das so nennen? Na ja, aber warum gibt es dieses Emoji? Warum gibt es Golfloch? Es gibt den Golfspieler, es gibt den Golfschläger und das Golfloch. Aber wie stellen die ein Loch da? Irgendwo ist ein Minig ja natürlich aus, als etwas fehlt. Ja, mit der Fahne. Mit der Fahne und dem roten Wimpel dran. Ja, klar. Wo das Golfloch. Ich habe lange gescrollen, da hatte ich mir Golfloch. Nehme ich als positiv, aber nicht so in your face so eingelocht. Aber ich weiß nicht, wie es angekommen ist. Seitdem keine Reaktion, seitdem geblockt. Seitdem viele Polizisten von meinem Haus, aber es kann noch etwas anderes zu tun haben. Wir müssen auch noch unsere Emojis einreichen. Oh ja, stimmt. Aus der Rubrik, Rubriken, die wir nicht abgeschlossen haben. Pokerchip, ich habe auch mehr mittlerweile. Ich habe auch mehr mittlerweile, ich habe aber auch vergessen mittlerweile wieder. Ich habe halber Smiley, Also Smiley versteckt sich, also Smiley guckt raus sozusagen. Woraus? Also stell dir ein lächelnden Smiley vor und die untere Hälfte ist einfach mit einer Mauer. Die Augen kommen oben raus. Ja, und er guckt über die Mauer sozusagen. Oder er versteckt sich und dann kann man ja auch vielseitig einsetzen. Ich habe Smiley mit Beinen. Smiley mit Beinen? Smiley mit Beinen. Aber wie groß sind die, müssen dann sehr klein sein. Nö, so Füße, kleine Füßchen halt. Ja. Smiley mit Beinen, was hatte ich noch, ja ein paar Fuchs und vor allem die Füchse, die aber, ne, anders, alle Tiere haben die gleiche Vielfalt wie die Katze, weil die Katze hat, da hat man irgendwann gesagt, die kann auch lachen mit Tränen, die kann Herzaugen, die kann weinen, die Katze kann alles. Der Affe kann nichts, der kann nur dumm gucken. Genau, Schwein kann auch gar nichts. Ja.
Es gibt ein paar Fögel.
Ja, Schwein hat die Schweineschnauze separat.
Ja?
Ja.
Okay.
Aber nicht die weinende Schweineschnauze und das Schwein? Ne, die normale Schweineschnauze. Nicht die Herzaugenschweineschnauze? Ne. So, und da finde ich, ist auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen Luft nach oben. Dann wie gesagt, der Pokerchip, das ist auf jeden Fall meine, ja, zwei meiner wichtigsten eigentlich. Also wenn du dich für eins entscheiden müsstest, das Pokerchip. Tablette gibt es auch nicht. Hast du meine dabei? Wüsste ich jetzt nicht, was ich da pillen kann. Die Pille gibt es, aber Tablette gibt es jetzt nicht. Es ist ja jetzt dieser ich glaube, man kann Neonazi-Ring in Chemnitz aufgeflogen, dieses Revolution Chemnitz. Ist ein Ring aufgeflogen? Hast du das gesagt? Ist der Neonazi-Ring aufgeflogen? Ring, das sagt man doch so. Ja, ja. Ich stolfe da immer drüber. Auch der Pädophilen-Ring. Ich stolfe immer darüber. Stimmt schon, warum sagt man Ring? Deswegen dachte der Herr der Ringe auch immer, dass es eher sowas ist. Du hast zwei Unterhosen angezogen. Aber es ist halt so... Unnötig um die Ecke fies. Ich dachte Ring, weil es nicht zentral organisiert ist, sondern eher sowas ist wie man reicht sich das weiter. Hast du Zeit? Ja, ich frag mal Bernd. Ja, genau. Bernd fragt Erik. Aber es gibt jetzt nicht sowas wie ein Clubhaus, sondern es ist ein System, wo man halt so Sachen weiterreicht, aber sich nie trifft. Keine Ahnung. So, und das ist aufgeflogen und dann sind ja diese ganzen Chatverläufe dann publik geworden. Und die wollten ja irgendwie am 5. Mai irgendwas machen. Und dann wurden die verhaftet davor, weil die Polizisten dachten, wir wollen jetzt machen, verhaften wir lieber. Haben sie den Ring in den Schicksalsberg geworfen. Ja, genau. Und ich fand es erstaunlich, wie unfassbar unkreativ die gechattet haben.
Die haben nicht mal versucht zu verstecken, was sie machen.
Die haben wirklich so, holst du die Waffe? Ja, aber eine schöne, gute Waffe. Ja, aber ich besorg sie nur.
Aber wirklich, wo man sich denkt, habt ihr noch nie einen Gangsterfilm gesehen?
Habt ihr noch nie euch Gedanken gemacht, wie würde ich einen Mord anstellen?
Ihr müsst das verstecken, Freunde. Das ist doch zu leicht. Ich meine, das ist doch, überlegt euch dann, hast du die Peng-Peng-Peng-Peng-Peng-Peng-Peng-Peng-Peng-Peng-Peng- neigt man zu Klischees, wenn man irgendwelche Actionfilme, also in Genres schreibt, wo wir auch nicht so zu Hause sind. Und dann fängst du an, leicht ins Klischee abzurutschen, weil du halt mit Filmen sozialisiert bist. Und dann denkst du, so würde niemand sprechen. Aber lustigerweise, Leute in der Situation haben natürlich auch oft die Filme gesehen. Das heißt, Leute, du neigst zu einem Klischee, wozu du ja neigst, weil es dein erster Gedanke ist. Das heißt, wenn du in so einer Situation wärst, würdest du vielleicht auch in dieser Situation zum Klischee neigen. Deswegen überrascht mich das sehr. Du meinst, echte Mafiosi haben auch den Paten gesehen. Ja, genau. Die sind auch Fans von den Patenfilmen. Klar, und die machen auch Türen langsam zu. Ja, was immer Nerviges. Und immer am Handy. Sorry, meine Mom ruft an. Weil die haben ja auch gesehen, diese Filme. Und das darf man auch nie vergessen. Deswegen wundert mich jetzt gerade sehr, was du sagst. Ich denke, es würde eher zum Überklischee tendieren. Das nervt, das hat mich nicht genervt, man. Das ist so, das macht das auch zu leicht. Das ist das, was an Nazis nervt, dass sie unkreativ sind. Ja, vor allem, man kann ja, also was ich ja zum Beispiel auch eine geniale Schlagzeile fand, Leonardo DiCaprio kauft
die Rechte am
VW-Skandal. VW-Dieselskandal.
Das sind so Schlagzeilen, wo ich mir denke,
das ist mal eine Schlagzeile.
Was hat er gekauft?
Erst mal interessant, dass das überhaupt geht.
Vor allem geht es nach deutschem Recht oder ist es
amerikanisches Recht? Ich habe mich auch lange
darüber gewundert, aber er hat die Buchrechte zu einem Buch gekauft. Das kannst du ja relativ häufig machen. Okay, gut, aber dann denke ich mir so, okay, da könnte man sich eine interessante Story vorstellen. Ah, okay, die wussten es nicht und dann haben sie sich heimgehalten. Wie ich dieses lustige Bit genommen habe und gegen die Wand geworfen habe mit Wissen. Und dann gibt es vielleicht ein neuer Praktikant, fängt bei VW an und wird irgendwie durchgereicht und dann darf er bei dem einen Projekt mitmachen. und dann gibt's der vielleicht neuer Praktikant fängt bei VW an und wird irgendwie durchgereicht und dann darf er bei dem einen Projekt mitmachen und dann bekommt er mit, dass da Zahlen gefälscht werden und so weiter und so weiter tolle Story und dann nicht mehr so wenn ich Verbrechen planen würde würde ich das so machen dass, ob die Tat jetzt gelingt oder nicht dass das geile Filmrechte sind, dass da was passiert dass da ein Drama Drama ist und dann so, und dann schreibt doch nicht so offen, macht doch irgendwie einen geilen Code, den man dann knacken muss und dann, neuer Praktikant fängt bei den Nazis an, merkt so, Moment, ihr wollt gar kein Baguette bestellen, wie Munition fürs Baguette und dann guckt er nach. Was heißt Waffen-Emoji, Waffen-Emoji, Waffen-Emoji, was braucht ihr? Ja, und dann fliegt das langsam auf und denkt mir so, Leonardo, Leonardo, hier! Und dann kauft er die Rechte und so. Will dein Name zu rufen? Willst du es so lange zu rufen? Ich würde Leo rufen, glaube ich. Ich würde nicht Leo. Leonardo, Leonardo DiCaprio, Leonardo DiCaprio, Leonardo DiCaprio. Mr DiCaprio! Wann ruft man nicht mehr, ab wann kürzt man ab? Frederico, Frederico, würdest du, Leonardo. Ja, es ist zu lang, es ist zu lang. Leo. Und das hat mich echt geärgert, Mann, ey, dann mach doch mal. Ja, das kann ich gut nachvollziehen. Boah, das Unkritt ist so, gebt euch doch mal Mühe, ey, das ist wirklich so, man kann sich denken, Genghis Khan hat hundert Leute umgebracht, Millionen, aber der hat halt auch irgendwie der hat ja auch irgendwie Stil und hat da irgendwie auch jetzt gesagt, komm, wir machen hier mal was. Ja. Nicht immer dieses Lachse rumgeplanet da, das ist ja wirklich albert. Wo wir gerade bei Überschriften waren, Story-Überschriften, ich muss ja zugeben, manchmal ist die Bild-Zeitung hilarious. Ja, das können die schon. Man muss es einfach sagen, die haben einfach, diese Dreistigkeit ist manchmal einfach zum Zungeschnalzen. Beispiel. Es ist ein Artikel erschienen über den Neffen von Hitler. Ja, das habe ich mitbekommen. Der heisst Alexander, Name geändert, weiss ich nicht. Und die erste Zeile in dem Artikel ist, der heisst jetzt er heißt nicht mehr als den Namen Hitler, schon vor langer Zeit abgelehnt, er heißt jetzt, und so müssen die alle nennen, Alexander, weiß nicht, Williams oder sowas. Und, aber natürlich, die Bild-Zeitung hat beschlossen, den danach immer knallhart, kann man was wollen, Alexander Hitler zu n. Und der ganze Artikel ist einfach, und hier wohnt Alexander Hitler.
Und das ist Hitlers Haus, Hitlers Freunde, einfach Hitler, Hitler, Hitler.
Die ganze Zeit einfach, fuck it.
Im ersten Satz müssen sie es rechtlich dann wahrscheinlich sagen,
damit sie es auch nicht trafbar machen.
Und da ist die Bildstellung des generellen Boulevardjournalismus
einfach auch anspruchsvoller als anderer Journalismus,
muss man einfach mal auch mal sagen, weil die da einfach, weil die auf Ethik scheissen und dann kommt irgendwann die rechtliche Grenze relativ schnell und da muss man sich dann verwappnen und da sind natürlich Überlevardjournalisten sehr gut sehr gut drin, sehr geprobt drin und das ist schon Wahnsinn, dann haben die ihn einfach die ganze Zeit Hitler genannt und hier ist Hitlers Haus und dann war da einfach so ein Haus mit so einer Amerikafahne und so, das sagt Hitler über Merkel, das sagt Hitler über Seehofer. Und man denkt die ganze Zeit, worum geht's da gerade? Aber vor allem, wie haben die den denn gefunden? Weil, also haben die in der Bild-Redaktion, sagen die, okay, wir sind 100 Leute. Ihr 50 verfolgt mal Olli Pocher den ganzen Tag, ihr schaut bei Steffi Graf zu Hause und Paul? Paul, komm mal her! Da kommen deine Referenzen heute. Paul, Referenzen, komm mal Paul. 90er Referenzen, ja. Pass mal auf Paul. Wo ist Hitlers Neffe? Wo ist der denn? Der muss doch irgendwo sein, Paul. Zeig mal in eine Richtung. Und dann lauf jetzt. Und stopp, stop. Schicken die Paul los. Paul. Intern Paul. Der halt dann nach 18 Jahren sagt, Leute, by the way, ich habe ihn jetzt gefunden. Also haben die aktiv nach Hitlers Neffen gesucht. Der heißt ja vor allem Alexander Williams, wo man sich fragt, wie habt ihr den jemals gefunden? Der geht ja nicht öffentlich damit rum, lauft ja nicht und sagt, übrigens, ich bin ein Neffe von Hitler. Wobei die Nachbarn wissen es wohl, die Nachbarn wissen es wohl, mit wem sich zu tun haben. Ja, wahrscheinlich irgendjemand hat den verraten, oder? Wenn er selber nicht so genannt werden will, gehe ich mir davon aus, dass er auch keinen Bock hat, jetzt in den Medien zu sein. Aber gut, er hat das Interview unschein gegeben, aber irgendjemand muss den gefunden haben. Also gibt es Leute, die aktiv danach suchen, die dann sagen so, der muss doch... Ich denke schon, aber da gibt es doch Historiker und so. Ich meine... Ja, Historiker laufen doch nicht durch die Straße, klopfen an Türen, kennen sie diesen Mann, das Hitler. Okay. Es gibt schon fanatische Hitler, nicht unbedingt Fans, aber schon auch Leute, die sich dafür so stark interessieren, dass sie, glaube ich, in Archive gehen und sowas auch herausfinden.
Das ist auch, glaube ich, sehr gut dokumentiert.
Wie viele Leute suchen Banksy gerade?
Ich glaube, es ist auch so ein bisschen so, man will Banksy nicht finden.
Weil ich glaube, Leute, die es könnten, finden das zu cool und schätzen es als Kunst zu sehr, um ihn aktiv zu suchen.
Ja.
Und ich glaube, deswegen, das ist der Grund auch dafür. Aber es ist schon krass, dass einfach alle dicht halten. Wobei ich glaube, ich weiß, aktiv zu suchen. Ja. Und ich glaub, deswegen, das ist der Grund auch dafür.
Aber es ist schon krass, dass alle dichthalten,
wobei ich glaub, ich weiss, wer es ist.
Ja.
Jeder heißt ,, ,,Ihm".
Ich hab mich danach, nach dem ganzen ...
Das Kunstwerk schreddert sich selbst.
Sorry, hast du grade Banksy hier gespoilert, hallo?
Ja.
Ich glaub, ähm ... piepen wir.
Ich glaube, das ist, ähm ...
Ja, hallo. Wir gehen wir. Ich glaube, das ist, ähm, ähm, ja, klar, wir gehen raus.
Oh nee! Sorry.
So, wir wurden rausgeschmissen, wir mussten umziehen, wir sind jetzt, wir sind jetzt draußen. Eine schöne, angenehme Abendatmosphäre.
Zwanzig bist du an Mott?
Fünfzehn. 15 Hallo und herzlich willkommen zur zweiten Hälfte des Podcast-Ofos, jetzt von draußen. Wir sind draußen und zum ersten Mal in der Geschichte des Podcast-Ofos sind wir draußen.
Freiluft-Podcast, ja, wir sitzen draußen auf dem Hof.
Und du hast diese, mir ist Kalt-Geste, hast diese Brrr-Geste. Nee, es geht, es geht eigentlich. Es ist eigentlich normal nicht warm. Was mich dazu bringt zu sagen, ich arbeite mal an diesem Bit, an diesem Stand-Up-Bit. Okay. Ich würde sagen, Klimaerwärmung ja, aber in Grenzen. Geil. Halt das. Das kopiere ich und dupliziere es, das ist eine Horde aus Florentin nach. Meine Idee ist folgende. Als Deutschland beteiligt man sich nicht an Klimaerwärmungsmassnahmen, also Maßnahmen gegen den Klima. Wie gesagt, das ist noch ein Arbeitsespekt. Okay, die ersten gehen zur Bar. Also, als Deutschland beteiligt man sich nicht daran, die Klimaerwärmung zu bekämpfen, sondern man macht so lange mit, bis wir hier immer gutes Wetter haben. Ja. Und dann sagt man, okay, jetzt reicht es auch und dann beteiligt man sich an Regenerative. Und dann alle Kohlekraftwerke ausschalten. Ja genau, aber solange bis hier so L.A. Wetter ist, so mindestens 14 Grad immer, also die Allertiefstemperatur ist 14 Grad bis hin zu muckeligen, also im Schnitt unmuckelige 24 Grad. Dafür hast du ja Tornados. Ja gut, aber wir sind ja auch immer gute Häuser von soliden deutschen Firmen, aber das fände ich mal ganz interessant. Einfach so lange einfach machen lassen mal die USA und China und dann irgendwann sagen, jo, jetzt reicht es uns und dann sich engagieren dafür. Vor allem Al Gore, für mich der Gewinner von dem Ganzen. Er hat auch den besten Namen aller Zeiten. Geiler Name, gute Botschaft, ja, Präsidentschaftswahl verloren, dachte sich, was mache ich jetzt, haue ich einen Film raus, damit in 200 Jahren, wenn die ganze Welt brennt, alle sagen können, er hat es ja gesagt, er wird in die Geschichtebücher eingehen. Ich habe es ja gesagt Typ. Aber was sind eigentlich die Top 5, ich habe es ja gesagt, Menschen der Geschichte, auf Platz Nummer 5. Auf Platz Nummer fünf, und ich mach's jetzt in der Reihenfolge, in der mir sie einfallen, Erich Kästner.
Erich Kästner war dabei, als seine Bücher verbrannt wurden, bei der grossen Buchverbrennung. Er hat die Nazis kommen sehen, er wusste, woran es endet und hat gesagt, nope, nicht mit mir. Und er hat's gesagt, er hat am Ende des Krieges gesagt, ich hab's ja gesagt. Er war dabei. Er war dabei. Als die verbrannt wurden. Ja. Wurde er eingeladen von den... Er war einer der wenigen, die sich da zugeschmuggelt haben, quasi, auf dem Platz, wo das verbrannt wurde, und hat seine Bücher gesehen, wie die verlesen wurden und ins Feuer geworfen. Pünktchen und Anton! Nein! Weg damit! Das ist meine Privatausgabe, ich hab doch unterschrieben. Warum Pünktchen und Anton? Das fliegende Klassenzimmer?
Klassenzimmer, können nicht fliegen!
Er hat vor allem auch Gedichte geschrieben. Du kennst ja nur seine Kinderbücher jetzt. Toll, Erich Kessner hat. Er hat tolle Poesie geschrieben. Aber wie das meine Grösse, ich hab's ja gesagt. Platz fünf. Ich weiß nicht, ob heute noch sowas funktionieren würde wie... Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Siehst du diese Wand, wo du gerade gegensteuerst?
Das ist die Wand der Rubrik.
Nee, nee, nee, nee. Nee, nee, nee.
Nee, nee, nee.
Nee, doch, nein, nein. Siehst du diese Wand, wo du gerade gegensteuerst? Das ist die Wand der Rubrik. Nein, nein, nein. Doch, doch, doch, ich nehme Anlauf. Stell dir die Moderation wie ein großes Gebilde vor. Du nimmst gerade Anlauf, so ein Tor, was du erst durch eine Abmoderation hochfahren kannst. Das ist noch nicht hochgefahren. Ich nehme Anlauf und ich nehme den Sprung und ich glaube, ich schaffe es. Weil ich weiß gar nicht, ob solche, ob dafür überhaupt noch der Wille da ist.
Sorry, wir haben die Tür ein bisschen zugebaut, es ist ein bisschen Aufwand jetzt, aber ihr kriegt das hin.
Entschuldigung. Ihr kommt da rein, doch auf jeden Fall kommt da rein.
Jetzt geht vielleicht links der Box vorbei, dankeschön, damit das Kabel nicht mehr geht.
Sorry, wir müssen leider ausweichen.
Dankeschön, Entschuldigung.
Wenn wir jetzt weg sind, kannst du kurz karkommen, ob wir noch laufen?
Ja, wir mussten uns leider komplett in den Weg stellen, um noch, warte.
Ich hoffe, dass wenn man nicht zurückkommt, Stefan vergessen hat, dass die Rubrik noch läuft.
Ich glaube mittlerweile auch, dass für so Nazi-Geschichten, es gibt ja immer so AfD,
ah, kommen jetzt die Nazis wieder und so, wann marschieren wir in Polen ein, ich mag doch Polen eigentlich, so. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir heute noch den richtigen Schlag Mensch haben, um das komplett durchzuziehen irgendwie. Ich weiß nicht, ob das einfach noch... Menschen, die Schlag Mensch sagen, gehören zu einem Schlag Menschen, die geschlagen werden sollten, ja. Zum Beispiel war ja gerade diese Geisennahme am Kölner Hauptbahnhof. In der Apotheke. In der Apotheke. Leute können sich aussuchen, du kannst ja als Geiselnahme aussuchen, wo. Du willst nicht als der Apotheken, geil, du willst nicht der, der bei Emolkal, wo ein paar Emolkal getroffen werden, nur noch auf dich schießt. Der willst du nicht sein. Top fünf Orte für eine Geiselnahme. Du baust dir die Wände zu. Top fünf Orte für eine Geiselnahme. Platz Nummer fünf, Grobac. Denn es riecht gut und macht halt immer schöne, gute, tatsächlich meine Theorie, Grobac ist eine Mischung aus Croissant und Baguette. Ah, Grobac. Grobac. Ich dachte, ein Gulag, lange, aber dann hat's geklickt. Platz Nummer vier? Platz Nummer vier,inske. Leckere Sachen.
Also mit dem Kopf die Assoziation gehört, ist alles, was sich jetzt am Bahnhof neben Krobag befindet.
Platz Nummer drei, Bällebad eines McDonalds. Es gibt wenige Eingänge, die sich leicht überblicken lassen und somit schwere Möglichkeiten für die Einsatzkräfte, von hinten sich anzuschleichen.
Platz Nummer drei, Waisenhaus.
Es kommt ein bisschen darauf an, worin du jetzt ein guter Geiselnehmer sein willst deswegen bin ich mal von der anderen Seite reingegangen und dachte mir, strategisch klug Platz Nummer zwei, Ikea leckere billige Hotdogs und so viel Getränke, wie man mich trinken kann. Billige Hotdogs, ja, du musst genau, und das ist eh schon billig und es ist eh ist eh schon wie so eine Riesengeiselhaft, durch den Ikea zu gehen. Naja, ich halte es für eine doofe, ganz, ganz dumme, dumme Aussage. Und jetzt warten alle gespannt auf Stephans Platz Nummer eins. Kirche, unbegründet. Und auf jeden Fall wurde dann aufgrund dieses Geiselnahme der Raum um den Kölner Hauptbahnhof komplett abgesperrt. Nicht nur der Kölner Hauptbahnhof an sich, sondern auch wirklich in einem Kilometer, kann, ne, ja, ich, Distanzen, in einem Kilometer abgesperrt und meine Wohnung lag tatsächlich in diesem Radius. Hä? Ja, in diesem Radius, wo abgesperrt wurde. Und dann hast du so einen Polizist als Geisel genommen, damit du nicht den Raum verlassen musst. Ja, und dann dachte ich mir so, mir nichts, dir nichts, ich gehe jetzt schon einkaufen, ja, bin rausgegangen, kam jemand bei dir, hat geknopft und gesagt, nee, das nicht, das nicht, die haben nur die Strassen abgesperrt und niemanden mehr durchgelassen, aber es gab ja Leute, die schon in dem Raum waren, also in dem Bereich waren, wie ich, der von all dem gar nichts mitbekommen hat, und ich bin einfach ganz normal einkaufen gegangen, hab diese Sperrzone verlassen, war Einkaufen, habe mit dem schönen Rettig geholt und bin wieder zurückgelaufen und komme nicht mehr rein. Ich komme nicht mehr rein? Ich komme nicht mehr rein plötzlich. Und dann habe ich mit der Polizistin gesprochen und meine so, ja, ich kann direkt auf meine Wohnung zeigen von hier. Ich kann da drauf zeigen. Auch ich kann von hier auf meine Wohnung zeigen. Ich habe die Frage, was dazwischen ist. Wie viele Schichten Beton. Und die Polizistin so mit einem Blick, das habe ich heute schon häufiger gehört. Ich kann sie hier nicht durchlassen. Ich muss nur da in die Apotheke kurz. Diese Apotheke. Die Polizistin letztlich meint dann so, ja, ich weiß auch nicht, wie lange das hier noch dauert. Ich habe eigentlich auch keinen Bock, hier zu stehen. Keine Ahnung, wie noch hier bin und die sagen uns ja nichts, die haben nur gesagt, wir müssen hier die Straße absperren und ich habe auch keine Ahnung und ich so, okay, sorry, sorry, sorry, aber das ist halt nicht das Mindset von Leuten, die Bücher verbrennen, dieses, oh man, ich habe eigentlich auch keinen Bock hier, so, weißt du, die haben nicht so dieses, wir ziehen das jetzt durch dich. Ich dachte mir, wo ist der Bogen, da ist der Bogen! Da ist der Bogen, er ist zurück! Es ist einfach so, wo ich auch das Gefühl hatte, wo ich am Ende das Gefühl hatte, sorry, sorry, ich will euch nicht länger stören hier bei eurem, ihr sperrt euch ab. Aber es war total albern, ich konnte dann einfach drum herumlaufen und von der anderen Seite ran. Von daher, glaube ich, ist es auch immer so ein Ding, die Geiselnahme ist vorbei. Was will man als Kölner Polizei macht, man dann noch so vielleicht so signalmässig so, wir sperren nochmal die halbe Stadt ab, damit die Leute wissen, da passiert was, aber es ist vorbei. Absolut, du kannst ja aussuchen, wo du jemanden zu geilen nimmst, dann nimmst du eine Apotheke. Dinge, die du dir nicht aussuchen kannst, pass auf, Dinge, die du dir nicht aussuchen kannst, ist, wie du stirbst. Und da wollte ich mir einmal kurz sagen, es tut mir unfassbar leid, Rocky ist gestorben. Und der grosse Rocky, über den Filme gemacht wurden, absurd viele Filme, und wie ist er gestorben? Der Boxer. Er wurde von einem Smart umgefahren. Er wurde, er ist überfahren worden. Oh nein. Von einem Smart. Einem Smart, und es wurde immer betont, und niemand, und ich war der Einzelne, der immer gelacht hat, wenn jemand gesagt hat, oh nein, Rocky wurde von einem Smart umgefahren. Warum betont ihr das? Warum betont ihr die Automarke? Und er starb und seine letzten Worte waren Was sind Smart? What the fuck? Es gibt Filme bei mich. Aber stell dir mal vor, diese heroischen Eye of the Tiger Sequenzen werden und dann so ein E ab. Ich glaube, das Schlimmste wäre noch so ein Tandem oder so, weil man vom Tandem überfahren wird. Es gibt nicht die Top 5. Top 5, wie du gerne sterben würdest. Die Flop 5, wie du gerne sterben würdest. Die Flop 5. Platz 1 ist smart, klar. Nummer 5 im Bällebad ertrinken. Platz Nummer 5 in Gulli fallen. Ja, Gulli fallen. Einfach wirklich so, du ahnst es nicht, guckst gerade nicht hin. Man ahnt es nicht. Du guckst gerade so, du zeigst gerade auf deine Wohnung, wenn du läufst und zack, fällst du in Gulli und das war's.
In Gulli fallen, ja. Ganz unüblich ist...
Ihr könnt schon raus, ihr kommt nicht anders raus. Ihr müsst nur so durch. Kein Problem. Alles gut.
Sorry. Wir haben uns absichtlich in den...
Oh, okay, das Ding nach... Oh, sorry.
Nee, überhaupt kein Problem. Alles gut.
Mach's gut.
Kein Problem. Ciao. Sorry. Sorry.
Entschuldigung. Danke. Schönen Abend noch.
Tschüss. Danke.
Platz Nummer vier.
Wie man nicht sterben will während der Podcastaufnahme
des fremden Podcasts über das Kabel schläubert und sich das
Gehlig brechen und dann müssen die da einen aufräumen.
Ich war ja gerade bei Pfütze. In der Pfütze ertrinken.
Ich glaube, man wundert sich,
wie viele Leute in der Pfütze ertrinken.
Ich glaube, es kommt relativ häufig vor. Weil es ist ja egal, die Wasseraktiefe ist ja egal. Es trinkt nur blöd. Platz Nummer zwei. Platz Nummer zwei, irgendwie bei sich aus Versehen bei der Olympiade mit seiner Pistole selbst erschießen. Es gibt ja die Pistolen-Schützen bei der Olympiade, auf die freue ich mich am allermeisten, aber es heisst ja nicht, ach, einmal die Leute, die korrigieren, es heisst ja nicht Olympiade, sondern es heisst die Olympischen Spiele, weil die Olympiade ist der Zeitraum zwischen den Olympischen Spielen. Olympiade ist das mit den Murmeln bei YouTube. Und da gibt es ja auch die Pistolen-Schützen immer so, die eigentlich die coolsten sein könnten, aber es nicht sind. Also die könnten so geile Revolver haben und so Hut und dann so aus der Seite. Wo man auch weiss, wenn dies nicht geworden wären, wären die Amokläufer. Aber es nicht sind. Also die könnten so geile Revolver haben und so Hut und dann so aus der Seite. Wohin auch weiss, wenn dies nicht geworden wären, wären die Amokläufer. Ja, genau. Die haben auch diese Gesichter, die haben diese News-Gesichter. Die hatten nach dem Abi die Möglichkeit, so fassen Sie auf, Frau Rieger, Sie können jetzt entweder Olympische Personenschützin werden oder Sie lassen Lidl in die Luft gehen oder so. Frau Rieger? Ja, irgendein Name halt. Hauptstadt halt. Frau Rieger, Frau Brüssel, Frau Tallinn. Ja, finde ich gut, man muss ja sich neue Namen erschliessen. Ja genau, das ist ähm, Platz Nummer eins wäre bei mir beim, ähm, beim Pantomime, also bei sowas solche Spielen wie Montagsmaler oder wie heissen das? Scharade. Ja, wie heissen die Scharade-Spiele? Herzinfarkt in der Scharade. Ganz schlecht. Herzinfarkt in der Scharade, so was. Herzinfarkt. Ähm, Tod, Schlaganfall, Schlaganfall, Liebeskummer. Ich hab's wirklich, du darfst nicht sprechen, ich hab's wirklich, Hilfe, Halt das mal, Halt das mal. Ah, Schneemann, ah, Krankenwagen, komm, Krankenwagen, Sanitäter, Sanitäter, Wiederbelebung, Beerdigung, Trauer, trauernde, trauernde Gäste, Erbe, Erbe, Trauer, Pfarrer, Graberede, Trauer, Witwe, ich komme nicht drauf.
Sagst du, sagst du.
Ja, das ist ein Problem.
Das ist wirklich ein Problem.
Irgendjemand muss Leute aufräumen, die sterben.
Irgendjemand muss die wegmachen.
Es müsste eine Endlösung her. Das ist doch dein Vorschlag. Du meinst, wir sollen nicht nur Bücher verbrennen, um die endlich mal loszuwerden, sondern ... Die auch loswerden, die sie geschrieben haben und loswerden. Ich habe heute was zu essen bestellt, kurz Themawechsel, und da habe ich einem Kollegen auch meinen Laptop gegeben, damit er sich auch was ausruhen konnte, und dann hat er auf Anmerkungen geklickt und wollte schreiben, mit Pommes bitte, die Autokorrektur hat, warum auch immer, aus als Pommes Bommels gemacht. Und es kam Mayo an. Meine Frage ist jetzt, was hat der Mensch gedacht, der mit Bommels bitte gelesen hat und sich dachte, ne Mayo. Was ist da vorgefallen? Vor allem, warum schreibt man als Anmerkung mit Pommes, warum bestellt man nicht die Pommes, tut die nicht im Warenkorb? Diese ganze Firma, bei der man da bestellen konnte, war schon mir suspekt, weil man konnte auch keine Getränke aussuchen, sondern man konnte nur Menüs mit einem Überraschungsgetränk auswählen. Und das Überraschungsgetränk war Cola. Wow, Riesenüberraschend. Und ich muss sagen, ich war nicht überrascht.
Ich weiß nicht, aber es gab auch keine Geld-Zurück-Garantie oder sowas, wenn Sie nicht überrascht sind.
Ich werde, wir werden Sie überraschen.
Ich dachte erst was wie Milch.
Von Milch wäre ich überrascht.
Ja, das stimmt.
Selbst von Wasser wäre ich überrascht.
Niemand, der Wasser mitgeben will, nennt es Überraschungsgetränk.
Von Cola war ich nicht überrascht.
Vor allem als Anmerkung schreiben, ja, ich hätte gerne noch das Hähnchenchenmenü. Also du kannst ja nicht deine Wünsche in die Anmerkungen schreiben. Genau, und dann war, dieses Menü war aber, dass man noch eine Menge in die Anmerkungen schreiben müsste. Unter anderem mit Bommels, bitte. Und dann kam Mayo an. Naja, die haben ja wahrscheinlich einen Erwartungswert, was normalerweise in den Anmerkungen steht. Und die wissen wahrscheinlich, da steht meistens drin mit Ketchup oder mit Mayo. Da musste irgendjemand die Entscheidung treffen, an welchem Wort ist Bommels näher dran? Näher an Mayo oder näher an Ketchup? Und das ist keine einfache Frage. Nee, ich wäre gerne bei den Brains damit dabei gewesen. Okay, Bommels, Mayo. Wir haben das O als Überschrift. Ketchup, Bommelz, gleiches Sins.
Also es klingt wie Pommes, halt die Fresse, Jeff. Halt die Fresse, Jeff.
Ich sag nur, es klingt wie Pommes, halt deine Fresse.
Bommelz.
Ketchup oder Mayo?
Bommaionese, Bommelz.
Bommaionese.
Bommaionese, Bommaionese, ja, ja.
Barbecue, Barbecue, Barbecue.
Ja, Barbecue-Näse.
Aber jetzt mal mein Auftrag an euch da draußen. Macht mal aus Scheiss, weil es ist ein lustiger Prank.
Kein Problem.
Sorry, es tut uns echt leid.
Okay.
Was?
Die müssen mit einem Kleiderständer gleich hier durch.
Ja.
Okay, wie groß ist der?
Sehr ungünstig.
Na ja, der ist nur zwei Meter lang und voll mit.
Aber muss das jetzt? Okay, kriegen wir hin, kriegen wir hin. Okay, wir helfen dann gerne, wir müssen dann noch gucken. Wir helfen dann mit. Okay, danke. Ausgerechnet jetzt, die sehen doch, dass wir podcasten. Also du willst sagen, schreib mal mit Bommels in die Anmerkungen? Schreib mal, ne nicht mit Bommels, schreib mal Dinge in die Anmerkungen. Schreibt mal, ich hätte gerne noch ein bisschen Schlumi. Ja. Schlumi und Bommels. Und guckt mal, was ihr bekommt. Einfach mal so. Ich finde es aber auch einfach gut, wenn alle Bommels schreiben, weil dann kann man vergleichen. Weil dann kann man vergleichen, was zurückkommt. Schreibt mal, ich wünschte, dass ihr den Tweet, der Tweet ist wie folgendermaßen aufgebaut, die Facebook-Nachricht. Eure lustige Nachricht, Anmoderation, wir haben es gemacht etc. Dann zwei Bilder. Einmal der Screenshot von dem Kommentarfeld, was ihr reingeschrieben habt, ob ihr euch für Bommels entschieden habt oder für Schlumi oder für Schlimi. Und danach ein Foto von dem Essen, was ihr bekommen habt. Okay. Dann können wir besser auswerten. Und dann setzen wir den Praktikanten daran und der soll mal auswerten mit so einer Excel-Tabelle, was dann da rauskommt. Der soll auswerten und dann merkt er plötzlich, Moment mal, da überschneiden sich zwei, Moment mal, der eine hat bei dem Restaurant Bommis gesagt, hat das bekommen. Und dann merken die, oh mein Gott, da ist eine riesige Verschwörung dahinter, die haben das selber gemacht, die arbeiten da, um Werbung zu machen und dann weiter, weiter und dann haben wir einen guten Film. Langfristig, glaube ich, man nicht mehr Wörter sagen, die man meint. Ich glaube, und da fängt es gerade an, spannend zu werden, im Internet mit Autokorrekturen so, ist auch langsam egal, was man schreibt. Also der Inhalt ist egal, es kommt nur auf das Medium an und bis ein paar Buchstaben. Du kannst ja auch, deine Chatnachricht auf dem Handy merkt sich ja auch, was du oft schreibst und passt dann die Vorschläge an. Also du kannst ja, wenn du sagst Guten, dann schlägt er dir morgen vor oder abend. Schick mir mal ein Bild von deinem und dann will ich mal sehen, was bei euch steht. Ja, Tukan. Mach mal eine komplette Textnachricht, indem du immer nur auf das mittlere Wort tippst. Da kommt eine komplette Nachricht zusammen und es sagt viel über dich aus. Das mittlere Wort. Ja. Es geht los mit Ja. Ich bin Ja- ja und Typ. Du bist ein positiver Typ. Ja, ich weiss, das wird ein bisschen zu Hause. Ist es, ist das, ist nett, wenn ich mich sehr gut aus und die Folge war, ich noch mal kurz für den Podcast auf der Suche nach einem Jahr.
Und die Folge war Ich noch mal die nächste Mal, die ich noch nicht klappen würde.
Mich sehr freuen, uns über den Weg nach Berlin ist es ist das ist nett, wenn ich mich nicht so viel Spaß beim ich habe mir das wird ein paar Minuten später noch einmal ein bisschen mehr So gut aus dem Ich hab ich noch mal kurz in die Folge. Wow. Guck mal, so kannst du ein komplettes Buch schreiben. Auf der Suche nach dem Jahr. Weil ich mit dir oft über Podcasts und Folgen schreibe. Ich glaube, und nach Berlin. Ich komme ein bisschen später auf dem Weg nach Berlin. Ich glaube, wenn ich es mit anderen Kollegen schreibe, kommt was anderes.
Wollen wir mal probieren? Ach, tatsächlich, stimmt.
Das war jetzt das Feld für mich. Das Feld für dich.
Jetzt kommt ein Autorenkollege.
Ja, ich weiss, ich habe
mir das nicht mehr
bei mir ist, das
denn für ein bisschen
zu Hause ist,
ist nicht mehr bei mir
auch noch nicht mehr
so gut aus dem
Vielen Dank. wenn für ein bisschen zu Hause ist, ist nicht mehr bei mir auch noch nicht mehr so gut aus dem Weg.
Es klingt nach dir. Es hat schon so ein bisschen deine normale Farbe, wie du schreibst. Mir ist mir aufgefallen sehr oft das Wort Ja in Sätzen und das Wort Halt.
Und ich, sehr viel ich, alles ich, ich, ich.
Halt?
Ja, das ist halt so. Da muss man halt mal drauf achten. Oh, das gefällt mir nicht. Das ist kein guter Stil, Stefan. Oh, okay. Halt, das ist so wie Fei. Kennst du Fei? Nee, ey. Fei? Fei. Doch, Fei. Was Fei? Fei, Fei. Ja, okay. Das ist ein Spiel. Aber Halt ist, glaube ich, kein gutes Wort. Halt, ich habe auch... Das sag's halt nicht. Guck mal, das klingt sofort unsympathisch. Halt ist wirklich das unsympathischste Wort der Welt. Ich bin halt jemand, der halt gern Halt sagt. Das klingt wirklich direkt unsympathisch. Haltmässige Klappe. Wow. Ja. Naja, ich muss halt... Ist nicht so sympathisch, das stimmt schon. Mir gefällt das ganz gut hier draußen. Es ist angenehm, es ist tatsächlich sehr angenehm. Wir haben ab und zu so halbe Gäste, so ein bisschen Durchlauf. So heißt die Folge auch, Rundlauf. Oh, Podcast-Rundlauf fände ich mal spannend. Dass man die Leute wechseln oder wem? Genau, dass zwei Leute reden und dann wechselt man. Und wer quasi den Schlagabtausch gewinnt, der darf im Finale um die. Dann darfst du um die machen. Um die. Ja, um die. Um die Angabe sagt man ja erstmal. Erstmal um die. Habt ihr das nie gespielt rundherum? Ja, doch um die. Anbau. Es gibt auch so eine Karte, so eine Deutschlandkarte, und dann sieht man genau, welche verschiedenen Begriffe an welchen Orten benutzt werden für der sichere Ort beim Fangspiel. Das ist super Sorgfältig, glaube ich. Ja? Ach cool. Die haben das damals mal erfragt und dann kam raus, was es ist. Ich habe bis heute, bis zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht gewusst, dass man beim Fang irgendwo schlagen muss. Bei mir hat man Leute gefangen und wenn du gefangen wurdest, bist du raus. Im Keller, ja. Ich habe jetzt nicht unbedingt diesen Freischlagpunkt nicht unbedingt gecheckt. Dieser Freischlagpunkt war für mich als dickes Kind sehr wichtig. Essentieller Bestandteil meiner Jugend. Erst mal gucken, wo ist der Punkt? Wo ist der Punkt? Vogelfrei war es bei uns. Und es stimmt tatsächlich, also du siehst dann auch Bayern und so, ist Vogelfrei tatsächlich sieht man. Aber ihr würdet es eher anders aussprechen vogelfrei also je nach je nach Gemütslage dann auch anders und in Hamburg heisst es halt auch vogelfrei nur man sagt es halt anders das stimmt es ist überall dasselbe Wort es wird nur anders ausgesprochen es ist sehr merkwürdig es ist verhext aber wo ist es Bommels ist die Frage ja genau das interessiert mich wirklich Bommels und was mich auch mal interessieren würde, reden wir gerade leiser, weil wir draußen reden. Ich habe das Gefühl, man redet draußen nicht in der Lautstärke, in der man drinnen redet, in den geschützten vier Wänden. Das werden wir später im Schnitt merken, wenn wir noch so coole Halleffekte drauflegen müssen oder so Vogelzwitschern. Das war die späteste Folge aller Zeiten. Nee, wir haben auch schon mal Nachts im Hotelzimmer in Hamburg.
Das war dieses Auswärtsspiel.
Das war aber verrückt.
Es ist das späteste Heimspiel.
Ja.
Ja, das war doch der eine Favorit. Wir sind aber jetzt gleich weg. Ja, das ist doch egal. Sorry. Okay. Okay. In diesem Sinne. Ah, da kommt der Kleiderständer. Das war die späteste Heimspiel-Folge aller Zeiten. Wir wissen nicht genau, ob jetzt erst die Folge kommt aus Köln, Hannover, oder ob erst diese Folge kommt. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Erst Hannover, aber das kann ich schon mal sagen, wir haben in Hannover leider, genau wie in Mannheim, vergessen abzuheben. Deswegen heben wir jetzt dreimal ab. Das heißt, technisch gesehen stehen wir noch in Mannheim irgendwo rum, ja?
Und wir müssen jetzt abheben. Macht's gut, haut rein.
Macht's gut.
Es kommen erst mal noch ein paar normale Folgen. Wir machen natürlich zwischen den Live-Folgen auch immer normale Folgen.
Ja, wobei ich bin nächste Woche im Urlaub, aber gut, alles klar.
Nächste Woche noch nicht, danach die Woche bin ich im Urlaub.
Ja, okay, gut, alles klar. Ansonsten haut rein, bis zum nächsten Mal, viel Spaß.
Und macht's gut.
Macht's gut, ciao.
Okay, unangenehm, draußen, alles klar.